WWE fans and gamers alike John Cena here
in case you couldn't tell and I'm chosen
to be the cover superstar for WWE 2k15
today is the first time in 30 year
history of WWE video games that we've
ever done a cover shoot for the video
game and that can only mean one thing
it's going to be bigger better and more
awesome this game is like no other the
authenticity is spot-on I am so excited
to K has a long lineage a wonderful
history with video games superstars such
as LeBron James Dwayne the rock Johnson
and now you can include myself in the 2k
foam I'm actually working really close
to 2k sports this year to kind of put my
own little touches on the game and I
can't kind of give away what I'm gonna
do because that's kind of a surprise but
i will tell you i'm going a hundred
percent and i am never given up to make
sure this game WWE 2k15 will be the
absolute best game you have ever got
your hands on ever played ever been
addicted to you won't be able to put it
down that's my word John Cena see you a
launch
you